in the last few moments
um we have had the evidence that Boris
Johnson has submitted to the Privileges
committee inquiry
um this is the inquiry looking into his
behavior
um at number 10 and whether or not he
misled the houses of Parliament uh the
submissions basically give an outline uh
to what happened uh how the revelations
in Sue Gray's report uh shocked the
public uh he also then says that he
accepts that the House of Commons was
misled by my statements we know that
already that he has accepted that he did
mislead the house so the nub of what
this report is about is whether or not
he intentionally misled the house or
whether he was speaking in good faith
and whether or not he believed that he
was actually telling the truth uh he
says um they were made in good faith
when he made them to the house he
accepts that the House of Commons were
misled but that they were in good faith
as I'm saying as I've just said
let's bring in our correspondent Ali
Fortescue who joins us now Ali you've
only just had a few seconds to glance at
this but what leaps out at you
yeah I mean look this is this was a
scandal that brought down a prime
minister with an ATC majority and the
Privileges committee already in an
interim report said that it must have
been they suggest obvious to the former
PM that covered rule breaches did happen
so this is a big moment this is Boris
Johnson's defense for what happens and
um and we're just reading it really for
the first time now but in um the fourth
paragraph on the second page he says I
accept that the House of Commons was
misled by my statement that the rules
and guidance had been followed
completely at number 10 but when the
statements were made they were made in
good faith and on the basis of what I
honestly knew and believed at the time I
did not intentionally or recklessly
mislead the house on the 1st of December
2021 8th of December 2021 or on any
other date I would never have dreamed of
doing so so um he this is obviously
um him saying that he did not recklessly
this is what the Privileges committee
are looking at did he recklessly mislead
the house when he said no rules were
broken
um his allies have really um focused on
two things firstly that he was acting on
the advice of officials he didn't know
that these rules were being broken
secondly questions about the Privileges
committee process itself I was speaking
to Juan Boris Johnson Ally yesterday who
said that this was a labor-led committee
of course Harriet Harman who chairs the
committee also questions about the Sue
gray report which
um as we know looked into the party Gate
scandal we know that Sue gray has been
talking to the labor leader kirst armor
about uh working for him so his allies
are shining a light on that but as I
said a the interim report has already
said that covert rule breaches must have
been obvious to the former prime
minister Boris Johnson will give four
hours of evidence to the committee
tomorrow that is going to be a
blockbuster moment his political career
hangs in the balance and as you say we
have just in the last few moments had
this long dossier think it's about 50 or
60 pages long Boris Johnson's setting
out his version of events and why he
thinks he did not recklessly mislead the
house
and Ali obviously I've been hanging on
you every word but at the same time I've
been trying to sort of speed read
through this document as we have in
friends up to page 29.
um the the house sort of Commons
committee has said that this written
submission contains no new documentary
evidence and that that's key isn't it
because we were perhaps expecting there
to be something like text messages or
any sort of written guidance that Mr
Johnson had been given to assure him
that what he was doing was within the
bounds of Law and that does not appear
to be contained in this document there
are lots and lots of phrases of Mr
Johnson talking through it I did not
recall a conversation I I do not
remember that
um so he's he's appearing to go through
each individual allegations been made
against him
um and giving setting out his reasoning
and his understandings of that point but
it doesn't appear that this does include
any new written information we've also
had a little bit of guidance Ali about
why this information has been released
to us today because we did think it was
going to be released to us last night
but the committee has said that it was
released it was given to them yesterday
afternoon but had a number of errors and
typos in it and they also had to redact
some names so that's why there has been
a delay but but perhaps are you
surprised that there is no uh new
documentary evidence contained in in
this alley yes I think that would be a
surprise I'm just going to read you
another section this is on page 36.
further support can be found in the
contemporaneous WhatsApp messages
involving me which are in The
committee's Possession on the 10th of
December 2021 I sent a message to Jack
Doyle stating is there a way we could
get the truth about this party out there
uh I've trusted the assurances that Jack
Doyle's and others had given me so I
wanted the truth as they had explained
it and as I honestly believed it to be
published I used party as shorthand
because that is how it was being
referred to in the media so this is
Boris Johnson talking about an exchange
with Jack Doyle who had been head of
communications saying is there any way
that the truth about this uh sorry I've
actually lost that message that the
truth about this party that we could get
truth about this party out there I
trusted the assurances at Jack doors and
other were giving me so I wanted the
truth that they had explained it
honestly believed it to be published I
used parties as a short sound so he is
basically explaining why he was using
the word party in a message saying that
he was basically following what was
being said in the media
um it goes on to say in another section
I understand that the Press was briefed
with the line covered rules have been
followed at all times at around 5 16 p.m
I cannot Recall now whether I had sight
of that line before it was briefed but
it would have been produced by the media
team and then presented to me based on
my diary I believe that I did not know
about or proved the line before it was
given to the Daily Mirror
so this is Boris Johnson basically
saying hold on I did not know about this
suggesting that he was acting on advice
of officials suggesting that he didn't
know about things before they were
briefed to the media so that I think is
a big part of his defense and I'm sure
we will also find as we get through this
dossier potentially questions about the
process itself
um worth saying Chris Bryant who had
chaired the Privileges committee did
recuse himself
um over claims that he had
um basically been biased against Boris
Johnson Harriet Harman now chairing that
privileges committee they will have the
power to reach a verdict on whether
Boris Johnson Reckless recklessly misled
Parliament and recommend a punishment
potentially we could be talking about a
suspension that could even down the line
lead to a by-election in his seat that
is we're not there yet
um but that is the sort of worst case
scenario for Boris Johnson so this is
certainly a big moment and Alia found
another
um interesting piece it's on page 48 I
don't know if we're able to bring it up
0.100 on page 48 which he's doubling
down on what he says I never received
any warning before any event that anyone
had any concerns that an event might
break the rules or guidance no one
advised me after any of these events
that they were against the rules or
guidance or more importantly that
they've been allowed to go on in such a
way as to breach the rules or guidance
no one came to me and said we had a
problem with a particular event that had
gone on unnecessarily in the cabinet
office or in the Press office the
committee has trolled the
contemporaneous documents and not found
a single record that indicates that I
ever received any such warning at the
time it seemed implausible to me that
there could have been unlawful events at
number 10 without one of my many
officials making me aware of it so you
know very much repeating the line that
he has had and given the parliament
already is that he believes if there
were concerns about events he should
have been told about them in advance and
that there is absolutely no evidence
that he he was told about them in
advance and because he wasn't told about
them he thinks he's off the hook and he
thinks that that he didn't behave uh
unlawfully alley yes that's right you
know he's basically saying hold on I
wasn't told in advance
this this wasn't something I knew about
it therefore how could I have done
anything differently as you say saying
that he never received any warning uh no
one came to me with any problem
um he says uh so yes Boris Johnson knows
one person put it to me yesterday who is
not on Boris Johnson's side on this
either
um he he will be found to have been
untrustworthy or careless stupid as they
put it for not knowing what was going on
um in number 10 at the time but he is
saying
um that he was never received any
warning no one came to him with any
problems at the time I'll read you
another section he says as explained
above prior to my statements to the
house I spoke to senior officials who
had attended the event on the 18th of
December it was reasonable for me to
find out what had happened from the
people who were actually there in
forming my honest and reasonable belief
I also relied on what I had been told as
I explained above I never received any
warning before any event that anyone had
concerns that an event might break the
rules or guidelines